للمزيد ينضم الينا من العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه الصحفيه والبحرين السياسيه صالحه
غريب اهلا وسهلا بك سيد ااا غريب قتل ليست
دوله مطبعه من بين الدول العربيه
والخليجيه التي طبعت مع اسرائيل لكن هناك
من يقول انه يمكن ان تكون ان يكون هذا
الاتفاق الخاص بوصول المشجعين
الاسرائيليين الى الدوحه بدايه
لتطبيع المستقبل ما رايك
همم في هذه النشره لا هو
همم اتفاق الذي تم بين همم قطر واسرائيل
عبر الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا ل-
تفسير وصول المشجعين الاسرائيليين
3,500 مشجع اسرائيل وعشره الاف مشجع
فلسطيني ل- اا يعني تسجيل اجراءاتهم بدل
ان يكونوا عن طريق مطار اخر غير المطارات
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي فان هذا الاتفاق هو
اتفاق ولن يغير موقف قطر من قضيه التطبيع
مع الكيان الصهيوني قطر ترفض مع شقيقات
الخليجيات الكويت وعمان وان كانت هناك همم
يعني همم تواصل لتفصيل يعني ما تتطلبات
الشعب الفلسطيني خصوصا في غزه او في همم
رام الله وبالتالي فان هذا كما جاء في
تصريح المصدر القطري انه همم لا يعني لا
لا يسيئس ممكن ان يغير في سياسه قطر تجاه
همم همم التطبيق في ما يتعلق بالمكتب في
همم في في في في مكتب في مكاتب الان
موجوده اسمها همم قسم العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه كل الدول التي لديها جمهور
سيحضر الى الدوحه قد يحتاج الى خدمات همم
دبلوماسيه مثل ضيع جواز او ما شبه ذلك فان
هذه الخدمه تسهل عليهم همم يعني الحصول
على خدمات الدبلوماسيه في موقع همم
البطوله كما جاء ايضا لابد ان يكون هناك
لديه بطاقه هي وهي التي تعطيه وتفسح له
المجال للدخول الى جانب همم السكن والى
جانب ايضا بطاقه تذكره الدخول المطر
غريب هذه المكاتب مثل ما قلت الدبلوماسيه
من اجل همم تقديم المعاملات الاداريه
للمشجعين
مع دوله
مسيه مع قطر هذه المكاتب تكتسي اهميه
لانها يمكن ان تتفادى اي مشكله يمكن ان
يسيس في حاله ما اذا كان مواطن من دوله
اخرى لم يتم تقديم الخدمات التي طلبها
لا توجد هناك
خشيه ان يكون هناك حادث
مع الاسرائيليين
لا اعتقد يعني احنا مثل ما قال صاحب السمو
امير قطر انه احنا اول وزير الخارجيه
القطري ااا نحن نرحب بالجميع لكن عليهم
نحترموا عاداتنا وتقاليدنا وقيمنا
الاسلاميه وبالتالي فان حضور اي عنصر سواء
كان همم عربي همم اخر همم مرحب فيه
سوف يقدم لكل الخدمات في موقع همم
البطوله وهذا هذه العلاقه حقيقه هي فقط
مؤقته لموضوع البطوله عندما تنتهي البطوله
وعندما يرحلون سوف يرحل همم يعني هذه
الشركه التي كانت تدير هذا المكتب همم
لوزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه اشكرك همم
سيد صالح غريب صحفي والمحل الاساسي كنت
معنا من العاصمه القطريه الدوحه شكرا
جزيلا